maybe we can start with the executive
summary from the report um there's a
bunch of kind of data points that you
put and it's summarized with web3
developers at an all-time high and
growing faster than ever there's 18 000
or more monthly active developers that
commit code in open source crypto web 3
projects and there was 34 000 new
developers that committed code in 2021
which is the highest in history
obviously the developers in the crypto
industry are an all-time high and
activities at an all-time high how does
that compare to like other industries
that are non-crypto is that a big number
is the rate of growth here a big number
or is this just no in this specific
sector it's big but we're still pretty
small compared to you know other types
of technology verticals it's kind of
both so one uh you know just from a
methodology perspective the thing to
think about here is this is in our
opinion probably a big undercounting of
what's happening um because we're
looking only at open source repos of
things that are actually published to
github and get lab but if you compare it
to you know uh the number of people that
are software developers like in the us
which is in the millions or if you if
you compare it to the number of people
who um write javascript globally you
know that's that's like tens of millions
of people
these are really small numbers and so
it's actually a little of both right on
the one hand
twenty thousand thirty thousand forty
thousand people can do a lot of damage
you can have you know world changing
software that gets produced by a few
tens of thousands of people on the other
hand i think we're still very early if
you play this out ten years and you keep
growing seventy to 100 a year
um you know you'll have millions of
people here eventually and so kind of
kind of both statements are true i think
yeah it's really interesting to think
not only about kind of snapshot and time
where we are but the growth rate and
trying to understand that you know again
you guys are really really bad at uh
kind of understanding the exponential
growth uh for something like this if you
think about like one of the fundamental
things that the human brain is really
bad at is exponential growth it's like
why we have this coping problem right
it's just like we're and that's why like
startup investing is hard it's just like
you take the stuff and you strap away
for five or seven years and and that
number gets really large and it has been
i mean if you look at that shape that
curve it's really impressive how that
growth is compounding right and so i
think it's a really really important
point it's like people this is why you
get this whole you know that trope i
think it's a bill gates quote of people
underestimate what's possible in 10
years but they overestimate what's
possible in two years and i think it's a
side effect of exponential growth so i
think that that's a that's a really
important point that you just made that
like the exponential growth here if it
keeps going it actually ends up being
really meaningful in five to ten years
yeah one of the things i think a lot
about uh in this whole industry right so
bitcoin uh kind of crypto web three
whatever you want to kind of slice it is
uh it's all market expanding
technologies right and i always use the
examples of obviously like an uber and
airbnb if you just evaluated well how
big's the taxi industry how big is you
know hotel industry uh you missed
majority of what the actual value ended
up being there's a lot of people who
don't own cars now and they just use
uber and so to some degree this industry
and this tech these technologies are
doing a very similar type of market
expansion you can almost like add a zero
to the number of developers that are
going to be needed compared to some of
these older industries uh and you know
maybe that's correct or not correct from
an actual number but like at least
directionally there should be many many
more if it works and becomes kind of
what you i and many other people think
is that is that kind of a fair way to
evaluate it when you go back and you
talk to people that were that were
involved with like uber series a you
know the the conversation people were
having at the time was well hey you're
raising all this money but can you
really be more than a billion dollar a
couple billion dollar company i mean the
entire taxi industry is only 12 billion
dollars so how could you possibly be an
ipo caliber company and your point is
exactly right what ended up happening
was not only did the market grow grew by
10x and so you know i think the learning
there is when you put
an app on somebody's phone
and and there are three billion devices
in the world like all of a sudden your
total addressable market goes way up um
and so actually you can hit these what
seem like really large numbers um you
know with kind of the markets that we
have today and so i think that's that's
where you look at things like um you
know bitcoin and obviously this is not
financial advice but you know the sort
of comparison people make is digital
gold right so they say okay this is gold
um gold could be worth 10 trillion but i
do think one of the lessons from the
internet is that these markets end up
being when you put them on a mobile
device and anybody in the world can get
them you know the markets often end up
being bigger and so then i think that
has sort of two interesting observations
on the developer side one actually takes
far fewer developers to get to these
really really large markets than you
might expect right so uber only needed a
few thousand people to to become a
hundred billion dollar company
you rewind 40 or 50 years and it
wouldn't have been possible right so
like the compounding you get from
software and the composability that you
get means that you can have a smaller
number of people have a bigger impact
and so the leverage you're getting with
software is just you know keeps
compounding so you know it may be that
you actually never need more than 20 000
developers to have something that's
bigger than digital gold i mean you look
at bitcoin in the report it's only
300-ish you know 260 i think monthly
active developers on open source bitcoin
and that's remarkable right there's
if you had a 260-person company that was
supporting a trillion-dollar market cap
like that's unheard of right that's
that's amazing and so i think there's
actually this thing here where you don't
need that many developers to support
really really large market caps um and
the flip side to your point if it turns
out that the market cap ends up being
way bigger than anybody expected of this
whole industry when you add all these
things up that also means you can
support a lot more developers than
people may have previously thought um
and so i think both both things end up
being true like you actually don't need
that many people to support really
really massive outcomes from a startup
investor perspective and at the same
time if those outcomes happen you end up
creating this whole industry that
supports way more developers than people
would have originally expected we have
one of the charts the bitcoin um kind of
developers by month joined um and one of
the things that uh struck me here uh was
if we look at the largest ecosystem so
let's say bitcoin and ethereum is kind
of the two largest ones uh bitcoin has
about a hundred new devs per month
coming in not all of them are retained
but when i first saw this i was kind of
looking through the report and i was
like oh that's like a bigger number than
i would have thought it was in terms of
a hundred but ultimately your point
about there's still only being let's
call it 250 to 300 you know
directionally uh kind of active retained
developers tells me that a lot of people
come in they start building some stuff
and then they move to other areas in the
kind of developer ecosystem but still a
hundred per month uh is like a
relatively big number is that how you
kind of read both the people coming in
on a month by month basis but then also
uh how we get to only 250 to 300 or so
developers working on bitcoin in an open
source way
over like multiple months or years yeah
i think it's a couple a couple things
going on there one i think contributing
in the bitcoin ecosystem is it's just a
little bit more involved than you know
it's just it's a there's a lot of legacy
code there it's a it's a pretty robust
system making changes by design in
bitcoin is hard right you don't want
this thing changing underneath you all
the time and so you know the the sort of
ramp up to actually getting uh code
shipped in the ecosystem and making it
useful is much higher um than it is in
other places where you know
you know like if you look at something
like ethereum or solana like the pace of
development is much much faster by
design right they're they're in a
different stage of their evolution um
and sort of philosophically i think what
bitcoin's trying to do is there's
something different right i think you're
reading basically right now what's
interesting is this is not counting you
know in some sense i think
bitcoin sort of suffers a little bit
from from the methodology that we use
here which is we're only counting all
the open source stuff right so this is
not for example counting all the people
working on all of the exchanges all over
the world
um that integrate bitcoin and obviously
bitcoin is like the base pair that that
every exchange in the world uh
integrates right you don't have it you
don't have a crypto exchange that
doesn't have bitcoin involved um and so
in some sense this is under counting
like the broader bitcoin ecosystem um
this is just for accounting you know in
some sense core developers that are
contributing open source to the open
source community